The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today's lecture
starts off with what
probably is the single
most important topic
in the entire course,
not just to date,
but in the entire course.
And it's a rather sneaky
thing in the sense that
takes a while to grow into it.
Things have been going so
smoothly so far, that perhaps
this point is going to be a
little bit subtle to make,
and we'll try to lead
into it gradually.
There are probably ten different
ways to introduce this topic.
And whichever one
you pick, I think,
any one of the other nine
would've been better.
But without any further ado,
let me talk about today's lesson
in terms of something called
the directional derivative
and indicate, in a
manner of speaking,
that when we deal with
functions of several variables,
especially in the
case that n equals 2,
there is a very obvious
geometrical interpretation, one
that we made some use of
in the previous lecture,
but which I hope
to make more use
of in this particular lecture.
Let's take a look and see
what the situation is.
Let's suppose I'm given that
w is a function of the two
independent variables x and y,
and I have that w is therefore
some function of x and y.
And I can now talk about
the graph of w, which
we assume is some surface.
And I've drawn it in
this particular way.
I take some point a
comma b in the xy-plane
on which f is defined.
And at that particular point,
I go to the corresponding point
on the surface,
which I call P_0,
which has coordinates what?
a, b, and c, where c is
simply f of a comma b.
That, of course, is how
you graph a function
of two independent variables.
The w coordinate, so to speak,
is simply the functional value
of the x- and y-coordinates.
Now, what we did last time was
we essentially said, lookit,
if we were to slice this
surface by a plane which
was either parallel to the
wy-plane or to the wx-plane,
we get special curves
of intersection,
and we use this to indicate the
idea of partial derivatives.
Now, without too
much imagination,
I think it should
be very easy for you
to visualize an arbitrary
surface over your heads.
You're standing in a
particular point on the floor.
At that point on the floor, you
visualize a coordinate axis,
which we'll call
the x- and y-axis.
Now, obviously, you can move out
from the point at which you're
standing along the x-axis.
You can move out in the
direction along the y-axis.
You can visualize
that how rapidly
the height above your head
is changing as you move out
certainly will depend
on whether you're moving
along the x-axis or the y-axis.
But the key point-- at
least, the key point
from the point of view
of today's lecture--
is the fact that why were
you restricted to either
of these two directions?
Why couldn't you
have moved in any one
of infinitely many
different directions,
namely from the point at
which you're originating,
you can move in any direction
at all, because we're assuming,
at least, that the floor
on which you're standing
is continuous.
It's unbroken.
You can move in
these directions.
And the idea that you get
can be shown pictorially
by saying, lookit.
Let's assume that we're
at the point a comma b.
We have this surface over our
head just as we did before.
But now, instead of picking
a direction either parallel
to the wx-plane or
to the wy-plane,
let's pick some arbitrary
direction s in which to move.
And now, what I'm
saying is if I now
take the plane that passes
through this direction
s perpendicular to the
xy-plane, that plane will also
intersect this surface,
passing through the point P_0.
I get a curve of
intersection, and I
can talk about the slope
of that particular curve.
See, ultimately,
this is what we're
going to be talking about.
Now, what is the slope
of that particular curve?
Well it's a derivative.
It's a derivative of
w with respect to s,
where all of a sudden we've
now chosen the s direction
over here to be what
we're going to take
our derivative with respect to.
In other words, it
seems to make sense
to talk about the derivative
of f in the direction of s,
evaluated at the
point a comma b.
In other words, just like we
talked about f sub x of a comma
b and f sub y of a
comma b, why can't we
talk about the derivative
of f evaluated at a comma b,
in the direction of s?
And if we want to correlate this
with the notation in the text,
observe that we call that dw/ds.
By the way, notice-- not the
partial of w with respect to s,
but the derivative of
w with respect to s.
Remember, the partials
were essentially
defined in terms of holding
either x or y constant.
Notice that in our general
directional derivative idea,
neither x nor y is
being held constant.
Notice that x and y are
varying as we move along s.
Notice, also by the way, that
once x and y are restricted
to move along s, they are no
longer independent variables.
It's a rather interesting point.
We talk about w being
a function of the two
independent variables
x and y, but as soon
as we pick that direction
s in the xy-plane,
x and y have to be very
specially related-- namely,
according to the equation
of a straight line that
determines s-- for that
point to be on the line.
And that's why we
talk about dw/ds.
w is a function of
a single variable
once you restrict yourself to
the particular direction s.
At any rate, the question that
we want to come to grips with
is, how do you find dw/ds?
Well, here again is the beauty
of our logical structure.
By definition-- this is the
same definition we knew early
in part one of our course.
dw/ds, by definition,
is the limit as delta
s approaches 0, delta
w divided by delta s.
Now, the thing is, what's
very difficult to compute
in real life is delta w.
After all, this w,
being f of x, y,
f can be a very, very
complicated surface.
And to actually find the true
change in w-- well, heck.
We already saw this in part one
when we compared this delta y
with delta y tan.
To actually find the change in
y was a much more difficult job
than to find the change
in y to the tangent line.
What we're saying
here is, lookit.
We already know how to
find the change in w,
not to the surface,
but to the plane which
is tangent to the surface
at our point P sub 0.
In other words, we
have already discussed
that delta w tan
is the partial of f
with respect to x evaluated
at a comma b times delta x,
plus the partial of f with
respect to y at the point
a comma b times delta y.
And now, what we
say is-- and I've
written this to
accentuate it, because I
have to talk very
strongly about this.
It's a point that, if I don't
make, most of you, at least,
will allow me to slip over
this and not even notice
that I've missed something
very, very crucial.
But let me assume that I can
approximate delta w by delta w
tan.
In other words, let's
suppose that delta w
tan is a reasonable
approximation for delta w.
You say, well, what's such
a big assumption about that?
And I'm going to save
that for the very
last part of the lecture,
because my belief is
that the subtlety is so great
that I would like to leave that
for the very end, and go through
as if the subtlety didn't exist
so that you get the
computational feeling
as to what's going on here.
But here's the
interesting point.
Notice that delta w is a change
in w as you move from the point
a comma b to some other
point in the plane.
It's a change in height.
Now, obviously,
that change in w is
going to depend very
strongly on what direction
you're moving in.
On the other hand, how
was delta w tan computed?
Delta w tan was
computed just by knowing
two special directional
derivatives known
as the partial derivatives.
You see, notice
that to get delta w
tan, I have made the assumption
that all I have to know
is what's happening
in the x direction
and what's happening in
the y direction, everything
else being determined from the
function evaluated at a comma
b.
So this is really a
very strong assumption,
that delta w is determined
pretty closely by delta w tan.
And it turns out to be
almost universally true
and we're going to save that
part, as I say, for the end.
But for now, let's
suppose that we
are allowed to replace
delta w by delta w tan.
If we do that, and we go back
to our definition for dw/ds--
namely, the limit as
delta s approaches 0,
delta w divided by
delta s-- we now
replace delta w by delta w tan
and divide through by delta
s to find delta w over delta s.
We have, assuming that this
is a legal substitution,
that delta w over delta s is the
partial of f with respect to x,
evaluated at a comma b, times
delta x divided by delta
s plus the partial of
f with respect to y
evaluated at a comma b
times the change in y
divided by the change in s--
delta y divided by delta s.
Now, remember, in the
s direction, x and y
are not independent variables.
In fact, how are they related?
Let's isolate our
little diagram here so
that we see in what
direction we're moving here.
We're starting at
the point a comma b.
And by the way, to get
the proper orientation
here, as I've drawn
the xy-plane here,
imagine the surface coming
out from the blackboard.
In other words, the height
is really being measured away
from the blackboard here.
That's where my surface is.
I move in the direction of s.
Here is a delta x.
Here is a delta y.
s has a constant direction,
a constant slope.
It's a straight line.
Call the angle that it makes
with the positive x-axis phi.
Notice that no matter how
big delta x and delta y are,
they are related by
similar triangles to what?
The delta x divided by delta
s will always be cosine phi,
and delta y divided by delta
s will always be sine phi.
And therefore, if I replace
delta x divided by delta
s by cosine phi, delta y
divided by delta s by sine phi,
I obtain that-- what?
Delta w divided by delta
s is equal to the partial
of f with respect to x
evaluated at point a comma b
times the cosine of phi, plus
the partial of f with respect
to y evaluated at a comma
b times the sine of phi,
where phi is the what?
The angle that the direction s
makes with the positive x-axis.
At any rate, notice, by the
way, that these things are all
constants once s is chosen, once
the point a comma b is fixed.
Therefore, when I pass to the
limit, nothing really changes.
In other words,
this thing that I'm
calling the directional
derivative of f
in the direction of s
evaluated at a comma b
turns out to be what?
The partial of f with respect to
x at the point a comma b times
cosine phi, plus the partial
of f with respect to y
evaluated at a comma b
times the sine of phi.
And what I'd like you to notice
is that in these two terms,
one factor of each term
is determined solely
by the point a comma b.
In other words, notice
that these two factors here
are just partial
derivatives and have nothing
to do with direction.
They're determined solely by
the choice of the function
f and the point a comma b.
On the other hand, notice that
these two factors, cosine phi
and sine phi, have
nothing to do with f
and have to do only
with the direction
s itself, which, again, should
make intuitive sense to you.
That if you're asking,
in terms of the surface
being up over your head, for
a directional derivative,
obviously, once the
surface is given,
the directional
derivative should
depend on two things: one,
what point you start at,
and the other, what direction
you move in once you've started
at that particular point.
And what direction
you move in has
nothing to do with
what the surface looks
like over your head.
At any rate, what we now do
is invoke our dot product
notation-- in other
words, this little trick
that we talked about when
we learned dot products.
This particular sum can be
written very suggestively
as the dot product
of two vectors.
Namely, I will
write this as what?
The vector whose
components are f
sub x and f sub y dotted with
the vector whose components are
cosine phi and sine
phi, because remember,
when you dot two vectors
in Cartesian coordinates,
you multiply them
coefficient by coefficient.
To make a long story
short, dw/ds is what?
It's this vector,
whose i component
is f sub x evaluated at a
comma b, whose j complement is
f sub y evaluated at a comma b.
I call that vector
g of a comma b.
I'm going to give that a
special name a little bit later.
But for now, it's very
important to notice
that this is not a number.
It's an ordered pair of numbers.
In other words, it's
a vector, and if you
want to think of this as a
vector, what we're saying
is what?
Think of the vector
whose i component
is the partial of f with respect
to x evaluated at a comma
b, whose j complement is f
sub y evaluated at a comma b.
Notice that these are
numbers, because a
and b are fixed constants here.
Therefore, this vector, g of a
comma b, is a constant vector,
and it's in the xy-plane.
It's a 2-tuple.
On the other hand, the other
vector, (cosine phi, sine phi),
hopefully, you recognize by now
is nothing more than the unit
vector in the direction of s.
You see, this is the unit
So if I now use my abbreviation,
dw/ds evaluated at a comma
b-- in other words, the
directional derivative of w
in the direction of s evaluated
at a comma b-- is just
my vector g of a comma b
dotted with the unit vector
in the direction of s.
Now, observe have two things.
First of all, when you
dot, this is a constant.
I can't change this
once a and b are given.
This is fixed.
So all I can vary is u sub s.
But u sub s is a unit vector,
so the only way I can vary u
sub s is to change
its direction.
Notice that for two vectors
of constant magnitude,
their dot product
is maximum when
the two vectors are parallel.
In other words, this will
be as big as possible
when u sub s is chosen to be in
the direction of my vector g.
In other words,
dw/ds at a comma b
is maximum in the direction
of g of a comma b.
That's the first
thing to observe.
The second thing is that
when they are parallel,
the cosine of the angle
between them is 1.
So the magnitude of
this vector will just
be the product of
these two magnitudes.
But the magnitude of u sub s,
u sub s being a unit vector,
is 1.
Therefore, the maximum
magnitude not only
occurs in the direction of
g, but it is also numerically
equal to the magnitude of g.
In other words, the
maximum value of dw/ds
evaluated at a comma
b not only occurs
in the direction
of the vector g,
but that maximum magnitude is
the magnitude of g evaluated
at a comma b.
For that reason, g of a comma b
is given a very important name.
And I decided to hold off on the
name until as late as possible
so that the name
wouldn't frighten you.
But the name is the
gradient vector.
In other words, the
vector g of a comma b
is called the gradient
of f at a comma b.
And it's usually written
in this notation.
An upside down delta.
It's called del, usually,
with an arrow over it,
or in boldface
print in the text.
And it's written this
way, and it's read what?
The gradient of f
evaluated at a comma b.
What is the gradient of
f evaluated at a comma b?
It's the vector, which
gives you the hint as to how
to compute the directional
derivative in any direction
that you wish.
Namely, in terms of
the gradient vector,
the directional derivative
of f in the direction of s,
evaluated at a,
b, is the gradient
of f evaluated at a comma b
dotted with the unit vector
in the direction of s.
By the way, you may
recall that when
you dot a vector
with a unit vector,
you get the projection of
that vector in the direction
of the unit vector.
In other words, the directional
derivative-- another way
of looking at this
physically is nothing more
than the projection
of the gradient vector
onto the given direction
in which you're moving.
And the important point is
that this particular definition
does not depend on
our coordinate system.
What is interesting is that,
in Cartesian coordinates,
there is a very simple way of
computing the gradient vector.
Namely, the i component
of the gradient vector
is just the partial
of f with respect
to x and the j component
is just the partial
of f with respect to y.
But that was a very special
case, because, you see,
i and x happen to have the
same direction, as do y and j.
For arbitrary coordinate
systems, this need not be true.
And I'm going to drill you
on that in the exercises.
But in other words,
what I'm saying
is remember the
gradient vector in terms
of a maximum
directional derivative.
Don't memorize it as a
formula, because if you do,
you're going to get in trouble.
For example, if I were
to give my surface
in polar coordinates, say w of
some function of r and theta,
then it turns out--
and there's an exercise
on this in the notes--
that the gradient of f
is the partial of w with respect
to r times u sub r plus--
and here's the
big difference-- 1
over r times the partial of
w with respect to theta times
u sub theta.
In other words,
the gradient vector
is not the partial of w
with respect to r times
u sub r plus the partial of
w with respect to theta times
u sub theta.
In other words, you don't just
mechanically differentiate
with respect to these variables.
And the key reason that you
can't do this-- well, lookit.
Let's just look at
this little diagram.
And I think the whole idea
will become very clear.
Remember that in
polar coordinates
r is denoted this way.
u sub theta is at
right angles to r.
Notice that u sub theta is
not in the direction of theta.
Notice that the
direction of theta
is sort of the tangent
to this circle of radius
r at this point.
If I call this
increment d theta,
notice that this
arc length is r d
theta, so the vector in the
direction of u sub theta
is r d theta, not d theta.
I don't know if you noticed
that, but coming back up
here for a moment, notice
that this was OK here,
because r was in the same
direction as u sub r.
Notice, however, that it's r
d theta which is in the u sub
theta direction.
Again, I leave most of
these details for the notes.
But I feel that if I don't
say these things to you,
it becomes very easy to
miss these points when
we talk about them
or write about them,
but somehow I hope that by
you hearing me say this,
you will be keyed
in when you come
to these concepts in the
unit that we're studying.
But I think the best way
to augment what we're doing
is by means of a
specific example.
Let us suppose that we're given
the surface w equals f of x, y,
where f of x, y is x to
the fifth plus x cubed y
plus y to the fifth.
And we want to compute
the directional derivative
of f at the point 1 comma
1 in the direction--
let's call it s sub 1, where
s sub 1 is the direction that
goes from the point 1 comma
1 to the point 4 comma 5.
Now, what we're saying
is-- and I guess, maybe,
if we look at these two
diagrams concurrently,
maybe this'll be easier to see.
Here we are at the
point 1 comma 1.
We want to see how fast the
slope over our head-- the w
value-- is changing in the
direction of s_1, where
s_1 is chosen to be what?
We're moving from
the point 1 comma 1
in the xy-plane to
the point 4 comma 5.
See, we're moving
in this direction
and we want to see how fast w is
changing over our heads, which
geometrically means
you draw this plane,
intersect it with the
particular surface here.
And this point, P_0-- what
we really want geometrically
is what?
The slope of the line
tangent to this curve
in the w, s_1 plane tangent to
this curve at the point P_0.
And my claim is that this
can be done very, very
easy from a mechanical
point of view
now that we have our
gradient vector behind us.
Namely, what we
do is, given what
w looks like as a function of x
and y, we take the partial of w
with respect to both x
and y, which, hopefully,
you can all do quite
mechanically now
based on our last unit's work.
We differentiate, first
holding y constant,
then holding x constant.
At any rate, we obtain what?
That the partial of
w with respect to x
is 5 x to the fourth
plus 3 x squared y.
And so if we compute
that at the point 1
comma 1, when x
and y are both 1,
this simply turns out to be 8.
In a similar way, the partial
of w with respect to y
is x cubed plus
6 y to the fifth.
So if we compute that
at the point 1 comma 1,
that turns out to be 7.
In other words,
then, by definition
of our gradient, which is
the partial of f with respect
to x evaluated at
1 comma 1 times i,
plus the partial
of f with respect
to y evaluated at
1 comma 1 times j,
the gradient of f at 1
comma 1 is just 8i plus 7j.
Very easy to write down
mechanically when you're
using Cartesian coordinates.
Now, let me make a brief
aside, an interruption here.
The idea is to emphasize what
the gradient vector means.
What this tells me is that if
I were to leave the point 1
comma 1 in the direction
of the vector 8i plus 4j--
if I were to leave
in that direction,
that would be the
direction in which
the directional derivative
would be maximum.
And moreover, that maximum
directional derivative
would just be the magnitude
of this gradient vector.
The magnitude of
that gradient vector
is just the square root of 8
squared plus 7 squared, which
is the square root of 113.
In other words,
what this tells us
is that the maximum directional
derivative, leaving the point 1
comma 1, is the
square root of 113,
and it occurs in a
direction 8i plus 7j
as you leave the
point 1 comma 1.
At any rate, getting
back to the main stream
of the problem, what we want
is a directional derivative
in the direction of s_1.
That means what?
We take our gradient
vector, which is 8 comma 7m
and dot that with the unit
vector in the direction of s_1.
You may recall from
this diagram here
that the vector in
the direction of s_1
has its i component equal to
3, its j complement equal to 4.
This makes this a 3,
4, 5 right triangle.
So the unit vector
in this direction
has as its components
3/5 and 4/5.
In other words, the directional
derivative of f at the point 1
comma 1 in the given direction
s_1 is just the gradient dotted
with the unit vector
3/5*i plus 4/5*j.
Just mechanically carrying
out this operation
leads to 52 over 5.
And by the way, this
had better turn out
to be less than this,
because this is what?
The maximum value that
the directional derivative
can have.
In other words, if we
haven't made a mistake here,
one of the checkpoints is what?
That the vector can't
project to be any longer
than what it really is in this.
It can't be more than
the gradient vector.
But at any rate, let's
now conclude the lecture
by coming to the part
which is probably
the hardest thing that
we're going to encounter
in the whole course.
In a way, I feel a
little bit like a man
who fell off the
Empire State Building.
And when he went
past the 40th floor,
somebody said, "How
are you doing?"
And he said, "So far so good."
And that is, we've taken some
tremendous liberties here.
And the biggest liberty
that we've taken--
and it's not just a liberty.
It's the kind of a
liberty that to solve
involves the foundations
of our entire course.
We are now at the
grassroots of what
at least the calculus of
functions of several variables
is all about.
And that's this trouble spot.
First of all, does
delta w tan exist?
That's the first question.
Namely, how do you know that
there is a tangent plane?
Just because the surface
happens to be smooth
when you cut it by a plane
parallel to the wy-plane
and smooth when you cut it by a
plane parallel to the wx-plane,
how do you that it's going to be
smooth for any given direction?
See, that's the first
intellectual question
that comes up in the
reading assignment that
has to be solved effectively.
First of all, does delta
w tan exist meaningfully?
And secondly, if it does exist,
how is it related to delta w?
And now, we come to that key
theorem, the proof of which
is quite hairy.
It's done in the text.
It's also done as
an optional exercise
to help you generalize
what's done in the text.
And it's the counterpart
of what happens
with differentials in functions
of a single real variable.
But the key theorem, which
I'll state here without proof,
is simply this.
Suppose that w is a
function of x and y
and that f sub x and
f sub y both happen
to exist in some neighborhood
of the point a comma b.
All right?
So far so good.
Now, here is they key
additional hypothesis.
Suppose also that f sub
x and f sub y happen
to be continuous at a comma b.
My claim is that if this
additional hypothesis is
obeyed, the tangent
plane will exist.
In other words, it's not enough
for the directional derivative
to exist in the x
and y directions
in order to guarantee that the
directional derivative will
exist in every direction.
But it is enough provided that
these directional derivatives
happen to be continuous.
And by the way, if these
conditions are met,
we say that f is a continuously
differentiable function
of x and y.
But I'll talk about that more
next time, or in the notes,
or in the exercises.
We're going to make a big issue
over this sooner or later.
But for now what I
do want to do is just
end with what the
key theorem is.
The key theorem says, lookit.
Just like with one variable,
if these conditions are met,
then there is a very
reasonable approximation
to delta w by delta w tan.
Namely, what the theorem
says is, in this case,
delta w will be the
partial of f with respect
to x evaluated at a
comma b times delta x
plus the partial of
f with respect to y
evaluated at a comma b
times delta y-- and notice,
of course, that this is a thing
that we've been calling delta y
tan-- plus an arrow.
And the arrow has the form
k_1 delta x plus k_2 delta y,
where k_1 and k_2 both approach
0 as delta x and delta y
approach 0.
And this is very, very crucial.
It's not enough, as
we're going to see
in the very next lecture, that
delta x and delta y approach 0.
It's that these things go to 0
as delta x and delta y go to 0.
Consequently, these
terms go to 0 faster.
They go to 0 as a
second-order infinitesimal.
And what this really
says is, look,
for very small values of delta
x and delta y, even when you're
dealing with 0 over 9 forms,
if you pick a sufficiently
small neighborhood of
the point a comma b--
and that's the key point, a
sufficiently small neighborhood
of the point a comma
b-- then delta w
is approximately
equal to delta w tan
And by the way, this holds
also in several variables.
In other words, I picked the
case n equals 2 here simply
so that we can
utilize the geometry.
Namely, what we're saying
is, in terms of the geometry,
if f happens to be a
continuously differentiable
function of x and y, and
we look at the surface w
equals f of x, y above the point
a comma b, what we're saying
is that in a neighborhood
of that point,
there is-- well, first
of all we're saying what?
A tangent plane exists to
the surface above that point
and that in a neighborhood
of that point of tangency,
the tangent plane is an
excellent approximation
for the true change in w.
Now, what happens is,
if n is greater than 2,
we can no longer use the
geometric interpretation.
But what is important is
that the analytic proof never
makes use of the picture.
And the key point
is-- and I'm going
to exploit this in
future lectures.
The really key point is that the
delta w tan never gets messy,
that the variables--
delta x, delta y,
et cetera-- all occur
as linear terms.
And this is why the so-called
linear algebra subject
becomes so important in
the study of functions
of several variables.
At any rate, I think this
is enough for one lesson.
And in our next
lesson, what we will do
is show how using
this key theorem
has its analog in something
called the chain rule,
just as it did in
the case of part one
when we studied functions of
a single independent variable.
At any rate, then,
until next time.
Good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabrielle
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.